[Applaudissements]
gamin je me rappelle de des nombreuses
légendes que me raconter mon grand-père
l'Arthur du pré desert sache une chose
et sache la bien comment s'est-il
toujours au tout début des temps on se
nourrissait juste du ciel chacun y
prélevait ce dont il avait besoin
ce dont il avait besoin c'est tout
allait bien jusqu'au jour où un jeu de
coupe semi en tête à vouloir faire
quelques réserves oh rien de méchant
un tout petit peu de plus que nécessaire
à mesure que les provisions
s'accumulaient dans la caverne le ciel
s'éloignait vous devinez peut-être la
fin de cette histoire
chacun a pris peur et commence à dès
lors à vouloir en faire des réserves
encore plus de réserve ce qui devait
arriver arriva c'est depuis ce jour
qu'on ne peut plus simplement se nourrir
du ciel mais qu'on doit se mettre à
travailler le sol j'ai appris bien plus
tard que cette légende n'était pas
tellement gruyèreienne mais plutôt
éthiopienne peu importe l'origine de
cette histoire ces femmes m'a toujours
peu importe l'origine de cette histoire
toujours est-il que cela m'a aidé je
crois à savoir raison garder ou comme le
disent aussi des anciens de la mesure en
tout mais une chose après l'autre
comment en est-on arrivé là à ce que non
seulement le ciel se soit éloigné mais
que le seul commence aussi lui à se
dérober sur nos pieds
pour savoir où l'on va vaut mieux savoir
d'où l'on vient non pour raconter cette
histoire
cette histoire du genre Romo rendons le
temps à taille humaine
relativisons toute l'évolution en une
journée de 24 heures
il faut quand même attendre jusqu'à 10
minutes avant minuit c'était il y a
15000 ans environ pour qu'on entre dans
le Néolithique et en 5 minutes il va lui
dernier il va être du dernier cri
d'élever soi-même son propre gibier et
plus impensable encore de cultiver nos
premières graminées on est dans la
deuxième de nos révolution celle dite
agricole des choses pareilles finies la
liberté mais vivre aussi cette nouvelle
forme de sécurité qui se traduit
notamment par la réussite de l'homme de
l'espèce sapiens sapiens sur terre de 1
à 2 millions d'individus nous
atteindrons les 10 à 20 millions grâce à
la à l'agriculture et à la
sédentarisation en découlant de la
naîtront les villes et les empires
plus que 10 secondes cette fois avant
midi pour vivre au 18e siècle la
troisième de nos révolutions
l'industrielle celle qui va nous
permettre cette fois d'être cent fois
plus nombreux sur terre un milliard deux
petites secondes encore et c'est la
motorisation qui explose adieu sert
cheval boeuf et tout autre traduction
animale les campagnes cette fois se
vident avec l'arrivée des tracteurs il
faut 100 fois moins de personnes pour le
travail au chat du coup les usines se
remplissent et débordent même de façon à
pouvoir garnir des fronts ou de
terribles guerres sévices dans le même
moment de c'est l'heure des grandes
épidémies comme la tuberculose c'est
aussi le moment des maladies de carence
qui ravage nos villes de nos campagnes
on est locavore par nécessité et les
aliments sont des vrais marqueurs
sociaux la volaille aux Antilles le
brouet et les navets au gueux
c'est à la fin du 19e siècle début du
20e que la chimie et la microbiologie
nous rendent enfin un peu plus fort les
normes d'hygiène puis les molécules de
synthèse comme la pénicilline
bouleversent notre médecine les
ingénieurs et les médecins sont les
nouveaux porteurs de lumière les progrès
de la science sont incontestables quasi
dogmatiques toute la toute la transgence
nécessaire pour nous faire vivre la
quatrième de nos révolutions celle qu'on
va nommer de la couleur de l'espoir la
verte les engrais et les pesticides de
synthèse aussi renverse les valeurs de
ce qu'il convient désormais d'appeler
l'agriculture
l'agronomie plutôt que l'agriculture on
ne cultive plus la terre en lui donne
des règles et elle doit se plier à nos
lois les résultats sont là les pénuries
famines et carence en tout genre sont
sur le point d'être vaincu du côté de
l'agroalimentaire motorisation et
chimisation permettent transport et
emballages avec la conserverie tout va
pouvoir se mettre en boîte ou sous
plastique c'est fantastique le monde
devient village les cordes ananas
s'invitent à notables et nous font
oublier les cycles naturels de
production les aléas de la nature la
production de masse la publicité l'accès
au crédit nous propulse dans la société
de consommation cette société où enfin
le temps libre et les loisirs se
démocratise cette société ou enfin
l'abondance et l'interdépendance ne
peuvent signifier qu'une chose la paix
si charmant acquise entre les peuples et
les nations en 1953 c'est le secret même
de la vie qui semble être décrypté avec
la compréhension de l'ADN cette
génétique qui nous aide enfin à
comprendre le vivant cette génétique qui
nous fait aussi la promesse d'un homme
enfin dénaturé dans le sens premier du
terme déjà celui de la nature d'une
humanité qui pourrait se passer des
cycles naturels et où tout notre système
alimentaire pourrait se tenir dans
quelques boîtes de Pétri les brevets sur
le vivant renforcent encore la
concentration de nos ressources
agricoles vers quelques oligopoles de la
groindustrie là où le paysan non
l'agriculteur maintenant là où
l'agriculteur ne devient qu'un
fournisseur de matières premières même
si dans les fêtes la paysannerie
familiale nourrit encore le 70% de la
planète
tout devient globalisé interconnecté et
qui dit connecté dit internet c'est en
1983 que les premières machines se
mettent à dialoguer entre elles ensuite
en moins de 40 ans on passe d'une toile
qui faisait juste de présenter quelques
informations un réseau interactif
totalement décentralisé quasi organique
et qui de plus apprend par lui-même une
toile qui pourrait donner les outils à
la énergie pour comprendre notre cerveau
et nos systèmes de pensée le dataïsme se
substitue aux scientisme dans cette
nouvelle fois la collecte l'analyse puis
le traitement des données peuvent
résoudre tous les problèmes de la
société tout se calcule il n'est plus
question de fatalisme plus que la pensée
globale c'est la surveillance totale qui
nous projette toutes et tous dans le
principe de précaution là ou même la
vieillesse et la mort se doivent être
vaincus
pour notre système alimentaire
le 10 mois ce que tu manges je te dirai
ce qui tu es c'est muets se transformer
petit à petit en 10 mois qui tu veux
être et te donner te diront ou te
dicteront quoi manger tout est possible
du glouton quasi suicidaire jouant avec
ses artères aux adeptes de cette
sobriété volontaire
on y est
ça fait 3 millions d'années ça fait cinq
Révolution il y en a eu une amie dit
selon c'est assis autour du feu une il y
a 10 minutes où on s'est mis à cultiver
et rien que trois dans les 10 dernières
secondes dans celle encore en cours
qu'on appelle la numérique cette
numérisation qui nous propulse toutes et
tous dans de nouvelles habitudes de
consommation voire de nouveaux
comportements
jamais nous n'avons aussi bien vécu ni
espérer vivre aussi longtemps que
maintenant alors pourquoi
pourquoi tant de méfiance pourquoi tant
peur au ventre porte s'intoxiquer porte
son prisonnier mais aussi peur de ne pas
savoir pas être reconnu par lettre
considéré plus profondément aussi de ne
plus savoir qui on est en effet si je
suis ce que je mange et que je ne sais
pas ou que je ne sais plus ce que je
mange alors est-ce que je peux vraiment
savoir qui je suis
toutes ces peurs alors qu'on n'a jamais
aussi bien maîtrisé la majorité des
risques c'est vrai tous les risques
vraiment ce serait faire peut-être
abstraction de ce petit détail d'une
planète aux limites finies du coup ne
serait-on pas à l'aube d'une nouvelle
évolution d'une nouvelle révolution
il est bien possible que cette
révolution la sixième selon notre
décompte soit celle liée à la
compréhension de notre système de pensée
et de nos modèles économiques pour
certains cette révolution doit à nouveau
porter le nom d'une couleur mais cette
fois que question d'espoir non plutôt la
spiritualité la bleue
la prise de conscience de nos propres
Villeneuve vulnérabilité combiné à nos
progrès technologiques doivent se
combiner pour que l'on revoit nos façons
de penser il est certainement temps pour
nous de devenir des homo-consommatures
sapiens des consommateurs avisés
alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand on
parle de consommation une partie non
négligeable de la solution se trouve au
bout de nos fourchettes trois fois par
jour vous le savez déjà sûrement on vote
avec notre assiette c'est à chacun de
nous de savoir ce que l'on veut être et
de choisir en conséquence quoi manger
cette réappropriation de notre
alimentation doit s'accompagner d'une
gestion un peu plus altruiste de nos
ressources les lois du marché ne peuvent
pas et ne doivent pas s'appliquer sur
les biens communs que son lot le seul et
l'air
ça peut tourner au vinaigre et on en est
tous je crois bien conscient bien
consciente mais même là il s'agit de
garder raison et espoir à témoins ce
projet d'une micro vinaigrerie née au
Burkina en 2003
une petite soeur fut conçue en 2006 pas
loin d'ici initialement l'objectif était
de savoir si ce qui était prôné dans la
coopération technique au développement
était tout simplement réaliste à savoir
l'accès au marché de proximité et en
circuit court afin de renforcer les
écosystèmes locaux et
lutter contre la pauvreté ça fait
beaucoup de choses mais on reprend la
proximité cette proximité est
aujourd'hui une valeur ajoutée en soi
il est sûr qu'on est aussi tous beaucoup
plus raisonnable beaucoup plus
responsable quand il s'agit de nourrir
son voisin son cousin voir son propre
frangin plutôt qu'un anonyme Pékin
lointain
pour les circuits courts idéalement
c'est directement du producteur au
consommateurs ils entraînent deux facto
un peu plus d'équité dans les relations
un peu plus de respect et de
bienveillance
prérequis indispensable au développement
durable ce développement qui doit
permettre de répondre à nos besoins sans
compromettre ceux des générations
futures
si on combine les marchés de proximité
et en circuit court pour renforcer les
écosystèmes
comment serait possible des marchés
pourraient-ils faire ça cela
sous-entendrait que nos activités
économiques puissent avoir un impact
positif sur notre environnement dans
vivant que non vivants
c'est ce défi que fait l'économie
régénérative et biomimétique son slogan
la nature n'a pas de poubelle les
déchets de lin deviennent les matières
premières de l'autre c'est ce qui
prolonge l’aventure de la micro
vinaigrie grâce au soutien de ferchen un
projet de recherche européen
Grangeneuve supervise des essais afin
d'évaluer les vertus que les anciens
prêtaient déjà au vinaigre vinaigre
justement élaboré à partir de deux
déchets non non plus des déchets des
coproduits ou des deux ou des biomasses
ici de l'industrie agroalimentaire dans
notre cas des trèches de pommes et de la
mélasse sucrière quels effets pourraient
bien avoir ce vinaigre afin de stimuler
la croissance des plantes ou pour
traiter leur semence quelles effets
pourraient avoir ce vinaigre dans son
usage comme détergent enfin quels effets
a toujours ce même vinaigre quand il
condimante un fourrage animal afin d'en
améliorer son appétence sa digestibilité
et il vous faut aussi le dire substituer
un conservateur de synthèse made in
China plutôt que made in chez nous
nos propres produits de la vinaigrerie
se doivent maintenant de devenir aussi
des matières premières si on a des
solutions pour la partie liquide avec le
Guinée on fait quoi de la partie sèche
les drêches de pommes épuisées en sucre
mais enrichit par les micro-organismes
dû au fermentation une des premiers
premières pistes explorées c'est de les
utiliser dans l'alimentation du bétail
mais pas n'importe lequel les vers de
farine comme source alternative de
protéines menu de choix donc pour les
ténébrions de Saint-Aubin sévère
comestibles et commercialisés qui
s’attelent désormais à diversifier à
nouveau notre diète alimentaire nouvelle
boucle de valeur on mange où on va
manger tôt ou tard ces insectes mais que
faire de leur déjection nouveau modèle
d'affaires ou des essais sont en cours
afin de contribuer à l'utilisation de
ces déjections comme engrais locales
riches en azote en mesure de réduire
notre impact écologique
stop on s'arrête là pour ce soir avec
les boucles de valeurs histoire de
prendre juste un tout petit peu de temps
pour la dernière partie de l'action vous
vous rappelez des marchés pour combattre
la pauvreté comment diable cela serait
possible des marchés pour combattre la
pauvreté alors que leur loi ne fait que
de que de divorcer et renforcer les
disparités alors que ces marchés ne sont
bientôt n'existait plus que pour ceux
qui font preuve de solvabilité
contre partie pour nous les riches
d'antisolvables nous voici victime de
nouvelles maladies dont abondance des
vrais épidémies tant psychique que
physique en réaction de nouvelles
habitudes de consommation de nouveaux
compartiments émergents le moins mais
mieux le lien plutôt que le bien et
surtout cette volonté de sobriété
nourrissent nos besoins de sens de plus
en plus cela s'impose que nos habitudes
de gloutons de manger pour manger boire
pour boire consommer pour consommer 9
plus assez de sens qu'il faut que l'acte
se dépasse de lui-même
arriverait-on à écrire ensemble à suivre
de cette histoire vivre une sixième
révolution aube d'un monde plus durable
est-ce que si on redonne sens à nos
actes nous pourrions faire revenir le
ciel à notre portée voir renforcer le
sol sous nos pieds
ça vaut la peine cerveau la peine de ces
essayer
j'entends les cours de mon grand-père
sache une chose et sache la bien c'est à
chacun de nous de remettre du sens à ses
actes manger pour partager boire pour
célébrer mais surtout consommer pour se
réaliser ensemble
sachant raison et mesure garder pour
qu'avec toutes ces initiatives proches
ou lointaines nous parvenions à éviter
ce destin transhumaniste et sectaire et
nourrir plutôt un avenir très humaniste
et solidaire merci
[Applaudissements]